[Music]
hi everybody so my name is Amelia I work
at distillery distillery is an applied
data science and digital advertising
company we are experts at using machine
learning to build models of to build
audiences of devices that we predict
will exhibit a certain behavior so today
I'm gonna talk about expanding digital
survey data so market research often
involves survey panels so perhaps
there's an ice cream brand and the ice
cream brand wants to know its customers
favorite flavor of ice cream to learn
that they can administer a survey so
they administer a survey and they ask
their customers what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream and then one thing
they can one way they can act on this
survey is they can then determine
different advertising messaging to show
their customers depending on their
responses to the survey so perhaps in
this simple example they want to show
images of chocolate ice cream to their
customers that prefer chocolate ice
cream and images of strawberry ice cream
to their customers at her strawberry ice
cream and so as we work in digital
advertising typically the goal is to
show ads to millions of devices but when
you administer a survey you can only get
responses from perhaps thousands of
devices at a time so that's where my
company comes in we can build models we
can predict how a user will respond to a
survey we can then take our models and
use them on our device universe and we
can build segments of devices that we
predict will respond to a survey in a
certain way so we build segments of
devices that we predict will like
chocolate ice cream then the ice cream
brand can serve ads to these devices
with images of chocolate ice cream
so it's a simple example but it's sort
of how it works so how do we build these
models so the data available to us comes
from the RTB ecosystem we ingest 40
billion bed requests a day and from the
bitstream and in these bed requests we
have information such
websites a person has visited apps user
has engaged with and locations a person
has visited today I'm just going to
focus on the models we build using
website visitation data so out of those
forty billion bid requests we see 1.5
billion website visits daily from a
device universe of about 200 million
devices and we have so we collect
website visitation history on all the
devices in our universe and on including
those that responded to a survey so when
we're building models our data set looks
like this right it's sort of cut off but
we have we see visits to up to 10
million URLs and we see those website
visits from millions of millions
hundreds of millions of users but any
one user as you can imagine has only
visited a small subset of those total
possible ten million URLs so we have a
very sparse a very large categorical
feature space but it gets even worse
when we're modeling survey data because
we only have thousands of devices that
responded to the survey and we still see
many many visits to many many URLs so we
have still have a sparse feature space
but we have very few very few devices
that responded to the survey so we
really need a reduced a way to reduce
the dimension of our feature space so
that's what I'm gonna talk about today
how we how we found how we reduced the
dimensionality of our feature space and
when thinking of how to do this we we
turn to natural language processing we
looked at research performed in natural
language processing because they have
NLP data has similarities to ours so NLP
data consists of sentences of words
whereas our data a small snippet is
shown here consists of sequences of
websites visited by devices both our
high dimensional categorical feature
spaces so words of X you probably all
know about is a technique used in NLP
it's useful it's popular it takes text
features takes words
and it embeds them such that similar
words used in similar contexts are embed
close to each other in embedding space
and therefore converting the categorical
features into dense numerical features
so if we can take art sparse categorical
feature space and if we can learn
embeddings for each of our urls we can
convert our feature space into a rich
dense numerical feature space so that's
what we did we took word Tyvek and we
used it to Train embeddings for URLs so
so we we can train the word Tyvek neural
network to predict a context URL given a
target URL we defined our context URLs
to be URLs visited either before or
after in sequence at our visited in
sequence before after a target URL so in
this whoops so in this example a user
has visited these URLs in the sequence
we are trained we're feeding the network
that were predicting from the the
context URL of hares the context URLs
our hairstyle calm and pop haircuts calm
and the target URL is short hairstyles
code with there is a dictionary that
defines a one-to-one mapping between
each URL we are training and embedding
four and a row in the embedding matrix
so in this example we're learning
embeddings for 50,000 URLs so our
embedding and our embeddings are
dimensioned 128 so we have an embedding
matrix that's 50,000 by 128 so this
works quite well so to get this to work
well we trained with the browsing
history of all devices seen in a
two-week time period which turned out to
be the browsing history of oops the
browsing history of over 400 million
users and that turned out to be a
sequence of over 15 billion site visits
and a portion of the data is showing
here just to show that many URLs visited
in sequence have nothing to do with each
other there's a lot of noise in this
data but by training the neural network
over these 15 billion the sequence of 15
billion site visits it's able to learn
patterns in the
and embed URLs about similar content
next to each other so we can visualize
the embeddings in two dimensions using T
Snee we can then cluster the embedding
show in here by rotating color palette
and we can zoom in on the cluster
zooming in on this cluster and this
cluster contains all sorts of URLs
related to travel research so it seems
to work but we found limitations with
this method so I just showed you how we
learned embeddings with 50,000 URLs but
if you remember we really want to embed
up to 10 million URLs and we want to be
able to do this with a network that has
a manageable number of parameters also
we're Tyvek requires a pre calculation
of a dictionary of the URLs you wish to
embed and we're receiving as I said 1.5
billion website visits a day new URLs
pop up all the time they disappear we
don't want to be recalculating our
dictionary and retraining our in our
network every day especially because it
takes like 2 weeks to train it well on
15,000 URLs so we wanted to find a way
to train our network with using online
learning so
that's it sorry that's not the order I
was expecting but okay so in looking
ways for ways to overcome these
limitations we found this paper so this
paper was published in nips in 2017 it's
called hash embeddings for efficient
word representations and the author's
proposed a technique to learn many URLs
with fewer parameters by using a trick
involving hash functions and also they
remove the need for a pre calculated
dictionary so this seemed to solve all
our needs so we decided to try to
implement it first I'm going to show how
it works with a dictionary so I'm going
to show how it's able to learn
embeddings from many URLs with with
fewer parameters than word today so the
way it works is like this so we have a
URL that we want to embed and this in
this example it's Cole's com Cole's com
has a position in the dictionary which
is uh M and M indexes this new matrix
which is called the importance parameter
matrix and M is also hashed by two hash
functions H 1 and H 2 to get 2 more
indices which index this the embedding
matrix so the two the two rows of the
embedding matrix are shown here bi and
BJ we then use a convolution layer and
take a linear combination of these
embedding matrix using weights in row M
of our importance parameter matrix to
get the final embedding vector which is
labeled hash embedding here the rest of
the network structure is the same as
word Tyvek so the reason this is able to
learn more embeddings with fewer
parameters is that we can have a very
large dictionary meaning that this
matrix will be very tall but the
embedding matrix is only K by 128 and K
is a parameter that can be tuned so the
embedding matrix the size the embedding
matrix no longer has to be the size of
your ear dictionary right so this is a
graph to compare the number of
parameters needed to train word to Veck
here on the left and Hashem beddings
with three different values for the K
parameter as you can see we can train 10
million URLs with fewer parameters but
we have to tune this K Prime
for performance right so how do we do
that we wanted a quick and easy way to
experiment with with performance of
training these these embeddings as I
said before they take a long time to
train to completion so we didn't want to
train a bunch of different methods of
training these embeddings that way to a
completion in the put them in our models
and look at performance of our models
that would just reduce the amount of
experimentation we could do so we came
up with this quick metric then what we
did was we took a what I'm calling here
a ground truth embedding we had our word
to vacuum bedding that we trained for 50
URLs over two weeks and we were very
confident in the results we then
clustered those embeddings and so we had
cluster labels for each URL we then used
those cluster labels and the silhouette
score and measured with each test
embedding that we wanted to test we
measured how those new embeddings
converged to our ground truth embedding
clustering so so this this metric is not
perfect but it's works well we can see
how embeddings are are converging to
what we believe to be the ground truth
over time as they train and so here's an
example of using that metric I'm showing
you the same plot again and on the right
I'm showing the silhouette score for the
three different values of K shown here
so in blue you can see how the
silhouette score as the hash embeddings
train how the slope score increases as
the hash embeddings train when using K
equals 50,000 we can then increase k2 to
250,000 you can see that the silhouette
score increases but increasing it
further to 1 million doesn't seem to to
bring any increase in performance so we
took that to indicate that we can use K
equals 250,000 to get there are the
optimal performance from our hash
embedding Network so I've just shown you
how we can train hash imbed how we can
train the hash embeddings to learn more
unique and to learn embeddings for more
unique URLs with fewer parameters but I
haven't yet told you how we can train
them with online learning so I'm going
to do that now so it's very similar all
you have to do is you replace your
dictionary by a hash function
so the hash function should show you
hash kohls.com and you get em em is what
you index the importance parameters with
and then em gets hashed by to further
hash functions the rest of the network
is the same the reason this works with
this network structure but doesn't work
with word Tyvek is that in order to
avoid collisions you need to have a huge
hash space so in this network structure
you can have your huge hash space
because that only defines the size of
this matrix which is is whatever n by 2
and and you can still 2k right so then I
can use the silhouette score again to
compare performance of embeddings
trained online to in performance of
embeddings trained in batch so an orange
we have our word to vac batch trained
embeddings and then in green we have the
hash online embeddings they seem to
train faster and perform equivalently so
that gave us confidence that this method
works so we train our embeddings using
tensorflow
we monitor the training using tensor
board these are this is a screenshot of
tensor board just for fun you can see
again the embeddings projected into two
dimensions you can choose a URL here
cruise law News on the side it shows you
all the the closest URLs and embedding
space to cruise law news you can see
there are all sorts of websites about
cruises we can select another URL this
is Subaru Outback and you can see all
the other urls are about tires and cars
and another URL this is I geeks blog and
the closest URLs are all sorts of
websites related to Apple products and
finally there's a website called
hypebeast comm and it's closest to other
websites about sneakers so so it seems
to work well so we can learn embeddings
we can learn embeddings that we can
train our embeddings online we can learn
embeddings for all the urls we see in
our data stream and so how do we use
these embeddings to model our users as I
said before we want to reduce our
dimensionality we have this large space
we want to bring it down to this small
space so
so how do we do that we have for each
user in our system we collect their
their website visitation history so each
user has been has seen a bunch of
websites each website has an impending
therefore has a point in embedding space
so what we need to do is find a way to
combine these points to give each user a
point in the embedding space and one the
technique that is easy and and seems to
work surprisingly well is to simply take
the average so that's what we did so now
all users in our system have a point in
embedding space so then we can build
models so in order to understand how
well our embeddings performed as
features we did this little experiment
we took four of the 40 of the standard
models we've build in in our in our
daily system and we took a training data
set of 1 million examples we then
sampled from this training data set
smaller training data sets so that we
could sort of simulate when we had less
data available to us each box plot here
shows the distribution of the percent
gain in AUC when using embedding
features compared to sparse website
visit features and each of these boxes
the training data set is getting smaller
so on the left you have a hundred
percent of the data of the 1 million
samples and on the right you have 0.1
percent it's only about 1,000 training
examples so looking at this box plot
here you can see that embedding features
perform about the same as sparse web
visitation features when you have a lot
of data so usually the models we build
have this much data or more but then if
you go down to the sort of number of
samples we use when we're modeling
survey responders you can see that the
embedding features way outperform the
sparse web visitation features so that
gave us confidence that that what we're
doing makes sense so I just told you how
we can build this reduce dimensional
feature space how it seems to perform
well on small when building models with
a small number of devices I'm going to
show you a quick example of how we had
how we worked with a survey company and
actually put these embeddings to work so
we worked with a survey company that was
working with the ice cream brand and the
survey company had ministered a survey
we weren't told what the questions were
but the survey come had then built
models to predict which of their survey
responders were most likely to be
influenced by advertising for an ice
cream for an ice cream company so then
they passed us the devices they passed
us 5,000 devices and 500 of those for
which they had predicted these devices
would be influenced by advertising and
what they wanted us to do was to build
models to predict to be able to
reproduce their predictions of the of
the highest scoring respondents so that
we could then use these models on our
device universe and build segments of
devices that the ice cream brand could
then go and show ads to right so we did
that we tried we experimented with three
different feature spaces the embedding
features are shown in blue and then in
green in orange we have the sparse
features and in green was another
experiment we were doing about clusters
of website instead of visits to a single
website visit to a cluster of web sites
and embedding features outperformed all
the rest and and actually caused us to
be the high performing highest
performing partners that the survey
company tested they did a big test with
a bunch of different companies and so in
the end we won the business okay thank
you
[Applause]
yes
right so that's sort of what we do when
we when we when we feed the data into
the model we we see the data and we see
like this the visits in real time right
so we collect them in a buffer and then
we feed them into the bottle and so a
tie if enough time has expired the the
buffer goes away so it doesn't
so so the first time we did this we use
like word to vet with like the first
part that I presented about using 50
URLs and word today and we trained that
for a really really long time and then
we we we clustered with basically with
k-means it's very easy to cluster these
things and and so then what we wanted to
do for a different part of the business
was to to label the clusters to have to
have sort of like groups of websites
that were about cooking or fishing or
whatever and so we we manually was like
a team effort throughout the whole
company we went through the whole
clustering and and labeled and validated
it so so it was very sort of hand
curated
for what
you have to see at least two right from
a from a user for
you mean with the once we've had the
embeddings or before we before I think
the question is what feature engineering
did we do before we turn to to learning
embeddings right so so my company has
been building these models for it for
years and it's actually so surprising
how hard it is to get them to perform
better than with the sparse with no
feature engineering and so we have done
things with recency like we have like
two versions of a visit one you know you
visited last week the other you visited
some time ever in your life so things
like this seem to work well but but
beyond that we weren't able to we
haven't been able to do much feature
engineering that that worked better than
the sparse features
so survey did is a relatively new
application for us most of the models we
build are we build models for our
clients that want to do a digital
advertising campaign so they put pixels
on their website and they so they tell
us who bought their product online and
then we build models like that so so
usually we work with much larger data
sets
we used tensorflow and tensor board like
I said so I wasn't the one so I didn't
implement the production version but
they so I don't know if I can speak too
well so well to that but but I think it
was pretty simple to get it to - with
the hash embeddings we were able to
implement it in production before that
we it was not practical to - to do it
so we do now that we have this Hashim
betting we can injured if we're if
there's a for you we don't embed all
full URLs because that would be too much
but if there's a particular full URL
that's interesting or a topic that's
interesting then we can we can just add
them into the into the data so we do
embed some full URLs I think the next
steps for the project are to to find
different ways to use these embeddings
this is one sort of use case but how to
incorporate them into our our standard
models and and different ways to
engineer features from them like maybe
we can use them to to engineer recency
features and other things like that Oh
something else we're doing with them is
we're building contextual models so you
know as as we go as well goes forward
less and less people want to be tracked
around the internet so so we are
building that cookie free models so we
can do we can use these embeddings to do
that really well because we are
basically the embedding is encoding what
that website is about so we can we can
take that the embedding and other
information we have at the time and
build contextual models
[Music]